hi everyone this is professor rhonda
science and today i want to discuss the
power series solution to the 3d
isotropic quantum harmonic oscillator in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics now if you've been
following us for a while you're probably
thinking that we've already solved this
problem in another one of our videos in
that video we write the 3d oscillator as
a tensor product over three 1d
oscillators and once we've done that the
solution is pretty straightforward so
you're probably wondering
why on earth would we want to solve this
again well today we're going to study
the 3d harmonic oscillator from a
completely different angle we're going
to treat it as a central potential now
this will serve two purposes first it is
actually generally a good idea to try
and find different solutions to the same
problem because they might give us new
insights in this context treating the 3d
oscillator as a central potential will
allow us to introduce angular momentum
into our discussion and secondly it
turns out that the mathematical solution
of the 3d oscillator when treated as a
central potential is really similar to
the solution of the hydrogen atom
because the harmonic oscillator is a
problem that we know so well if we
tackle it first it'll give us the
confidence that we will need to then
solve the harder problem of the hydrogen
atom today we're going to focus on the
mathematical solution of the problem but
there is also a companion video where we
will take the mathematical solution that
we're going to derive today and we
explore the first few energy eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions so i really encourage
you to check out that video as well so
let's go
let's think about the three-dimensional
isotropic quantum harmonic oscillator
working in the position representation
and using cartesian coordinates the
hamiltonian h has a kinetic energy term
and then the defining feature of
harmonic oscillator is the quadratic
form of the potential energy term which
in three dimensions can be separated
into a term proportional to x squared a
term proportional to y squared
and a term proportional to z squared
if we now insist that we have an
isotropic oscillator
this means that the frequencies are the
same along every cartesian direction
and we are simply going to call them
omega
we can then rewrite the hamiltonian with
the same kinetic energy
and for the potential energy we can take
this common factor multiplied by this
sum of squares
and with this we can see that the
potential no longer depends on the
individual x y and z but only on the sum
of the squares
using spherical coordinates this is
simply the square of the distance r from
the origin
and this means that we can rewrite the
hamiltonian of a three-dimensional
isotropic oscillator in spherical
coordinates with the usual kinetic
energy term
and a potential energy term that is
equal to one half m omega squared r
squared
and this here is the key to today's
video the three-dimensional isotropic
quantum harmonic oscillator is described
by a central potential
for completeness we can also write down
the hamiltonian h by spelling out the
kinetic energy term in spherical
coordinates and as discussed in the
video on central potentials it is given
by this prefactor multiplied by a term
that involves the derivative of r and
then a long term that involves the
derivatives of the angular variables
and finally don't forget the potential
energy term
we're now ready for this video
what we will do today is to use our
knowledge about central potentials to
solve the eigenvalue equation of this
hamiltonian
and if you need a refresher about
central potentials you can find every
single relevant link in the description
as we've just discussed the
three-dimensional isotropic oscillator
is an example of the central potential
using this hamiltonian we can build its
eigenvalue equation like this
whereas usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigenfunctions
and our objective today is to solve this
eigenvalue equation
in the videos on central potentials we
learned that the hamiltonian describing
a central potential commutes with the
orbital angular momentum operators
what does that mean
it means that the eigenfunctions of the
hamiltonian can be chosen to also be
eigenfunctions of the squared orbital
angular momentum
and eigenfunctions of the z component of
orbital angular momentum
now you'll remember from our series on
angular momentum that in the l squared
eigenvalue here
small l can only take non-negative
integer values
and that for the lz eigenvalue here
for a given
small l
ml can only take one of these values
and if you need a refresher about
orbital angular momentum you can also
find all the relevant videos in the
description
another important result from the videos
on central potentials is that the common
eigenfunctions can be labeled by the
three quantum numbers k l and ml like
this
now l and ml are the quantum numbers
associated with orbital angular momentum
and k gives us the energy spectrum for a
given l and ml
we can also find that the energy
eigenvalues can be labeled with k and l
but that they don't actually depend on
the ml quantum number
the next key insight that we learned in
the videos on central potentials is that
these three equations imply that we can
write the common eigen function psi
as a product of a function r that only
depends on the radial coordinate
and another function y that only depends
on the angular coordinates
these functions y are called the
spherical harmonics and are labeled by
the angular momentum quantum numbers l
and ml
we have a full video on these spherical
harmonics and as always you can find at
the link in the description
the important result for us today is
that the spherical harmonics are the
same for any central potential which
means that we already have the solution
of the angular part of the
eigenfunctions of the isotropic harmonic
oscillator before we even start it is
given by the spherical harmonics
this part here is called the radial part
of the eigenfunction and it depends on
the quantum numbers k and l but we found
in the videos on central potentials that
it doesn't depend on ml
this radial part is the most interesting
part because its form depends on this
specific central potential that we have
and so the aim of today's video is to
determine this variable function for the
specific case of an isotropic harmonic
oscillator
now a quick important note before we
delve into the solution
today's focus is on the maths which is
i'm not going to lie to you a bit
lengthy
but it provides a nice example of what
is involved in solving eigenvalue
equations of central potentials which is
going to be really good practice for
looking at more interesting problems
such as the hydrogen atom
and of course once we've solved the mass
we can then explore the physics
we have a companion video where we take
today's mathematical solution and
explore in detail a few examples of the
energy eigenvalues and eigenfunctions of
the three-dimensional isotropic
oscillator
i really encourage you to also check it
out and the link as always is in the
description
so
all we really have left to do
is to determine the radial part of the
eigenfunctions
as we learned in the videos on central
potentials the radial function obeys the
so-called radial equation and we have a
full video discussing some general
features of this radial equation
just as a quick reminder what we learn
in that video is that the radial
equation is given by a kinetic energy
like term in the coordinate r
a term that depends on the l quantum
number
and the central potential itself
all acting on the radial function
and equal to the energy eigenvalue
multiplying the radial function
both energy eigenvalues here and radial
functions here only depend on the k and
l quantum numbers
this is the first step of our solution
as we already know the angular
dependence of psi
we can reduce the full eigenvalue
equation for psi into this new
differential equation that will allow us
to determine the radial part
so we're all set
in the rest of this video we will simply
solve this differential equation
the first step is one we already
discussed in the video on the radial
equation of central potentials
it is convenient to make a change of
variables and set the radial function as
equal to one over r times a new function
u
with this new definition we can rewrite
the radial equation as given by this
long differential operator
acting on the u function and equal to
the eigenvalue times the u function
so what have we really accomplished
this new equation for you is simpler
than the original one for r
because this differential operator has a
simpler form
there is though an extra point
to ensure that we get physically valid
solutions we also have a boundary
condition on the u function which when
evaluated at the origin must
vanish now everything we've discussed so
far is true for any central potential
and for the full derivation i
once again refer you to the
corresponding videos that are linked in
the description
the new thing that we will do today is
to actually solve this differential
equation for the isotropic harmonic
oscillator
solving this equation will allow us to
determine the u function and then we can
use it to build the radial part of the
energy eigenfunctions from this relation
up here
we are going to tackle this differential
equation postulating a power series
solution
a general strategy that is also used to
solve other problems such as the
hydrogen atom
but before we postulate the power series
we're going to try and simplify the form
of the u function further by considering
a particular limit
that limit is the limit of r going to
infinity
in this limit we have that this term
proportional to r squared dominates over
this other term that has r in the
denominator and over this term that is a
constant
as such we can approximate the full
differential equation as containing the
derivative term
and the quadratic term
all acting on the function u and all
equal to zero
in this limit the dominant terms of the
solution are this positive exponential
and this negative exponential
and you can check this by plugging them
into the differential equation and
you'll find that the derivative leads to
a term proportional to r squared times
the exponentials and another term
proportional to the exponentials
in the limit of larger this second term
can be neglected
moving on these two solutions are
clearly not the full solution because we
are neglecting two terms in the
differential equation
however this is what we expect the
solutions to look like in the limit of
large r
now note that of the two solutions only
the negative exponential is in fact a
physically acceptable solution
and this is because the other solution
diverges for large r and would lead to
solutions that cannot be normalized
so why did we bother with this limit in
the first place
what we're going to do next is to go
back to the full range of allowed values
of r
and inspired by this limit behavior that
we've identified
we will write the true u function as
equal to this exponential
times a new function that we're going to
call v
so what do we accomplish with this
change
as we know what the solution must look
like in the limit of large r by singling
it out we are hoping that this will lead
to simpler maths
but before we go on note that by
singling out the negative exponential we
haven't actually removed the unphysical
positive exponential solution so we're
still going to have to deal with that
later on
let's now see what the differential
equation becomes with this latest change
remember that we are rewriting the
function u as equal to this exponential
times this new function v
the tricky term is the derivative here
so let's write the second derivative of
the new expression in terms of v
we can now use the chain rule to expand
the derivative as the term involving the
second derivative of the exponential
plus the cross term which is two times
the first derivative of the first term
times the first derivative of the second
term
plus the term involving the second
derivative of v
we can now consider this term which is
the first derivative of the exponential
and we can easily evaluate it
from it we can also evaluate the second
derivative of the exponential
plugging in this expression for the
first derivative
we then again use the chain rule getting
this term
plus this term
putting everything together in the
second derivative
we start with an exponential common
factor
then considering this first term up here
we get a term proportional to the
function v
from this middle term up here we get a
term proportional to the first
derivative of v
and from this final term up here we get
a term proportional to the second
derivative of v
let's make some room
and let's copy the latest expression we
got for this second derivative
we can now insert this expression we got
for the derivative inside the
differential equation all the way up
here
and we end up with the common
exponential factor
we can copy the long derivative term we
just derived
and then we have the l dependent term
the central potential term for the
isotropic oscillator and we are now
moving the energy eigenvalue to the side
of the equation
or acting on v and or equal to zero
we can take a final step to further
simplify the form of this equation
first we can remove the common
exponential factor as we are equating to
zero
also these two terms combine to one-half
h-bar omega
and these two terms combine to minus one
half m omega squared r squared
we can then cancel this term with this
central potential term
and overall we end up with a term
proportional to the second derivative of
v
a time proportional to the first
derivative of v
and a term proportional to v
all equal to zero
in this last step all we've done is to
rearrange the expression above
but feel free to pause here for a moment
to make sure that you really are happy
with all of this
so this is the latest differential
equation that we've derived and solving
it will give us the function v
but before we do that remember that we
had a boundary condition for the
function u such that it vanishes at the
origin
remembering the relationship between the
u and v functions
we can straight away conclude that we
get an analogous boundary condition for
v
this is a good moment to recap
solving this equation will allow us to
determine v once we've got v we will be
able to calculate u using this relation
between the two
and once we've got u we will be able to
get the original radial function r using
this relation between the two
finally once we've got the radial
function we will be able to build the
full eigenfunction psi
and this will be accomplished by
multiplying r with the corresponding
spherical harmonics
now i realize that this may look like a
rather convoluted path to determine the
eigenfunctions but at the end of the day
we started with a really complex
differential equation so we never
expected the solution to be
straightforward but we're now ready for
the final push
all we have left to do is to find out
what v is
and as we anticipated a few minutes ago
we are going to write v as a power
series
we set it equal to r to the paris
and then a power series in r
we can also rewrite it by taking the r
to the power s inside the sum
and note that we're starting the power
series at q equals zero what this means
is that by definition we choose c zero
to the lowest non-zero coefficient or to
put it another way as we insist that the
q zero term in this sum is non-zero then
the lowest power in the expansion is
this s here
of course this choice will not affect
the final answer it's just a convenient
way for us to write the power series
looking at the differential equation at
the top we see that the tricky terms
will be the derivatives
if we start with the first derivative of
v we can write it as the derivative of
the power series
and we can very easily calculate the
derivative of each power in the sum to
get this new sum
now similarly we can consider the second
derivative of v and this is equal to the
first derivative of this expression that
we've just derived
and we can again easily evaluate the
derivatives of the powers to get this
other sum
we're now ready to rewrite the full
differential equation at the top in
terms of the power series
every term will feature the summation
over the c coefficients so we can start
with that
we then have the first term at the top
here which involves the free factor and
then the second derivative of the power
series that we've just derived
and note that the power is q plus s
minus 2.
moving to the second term at the top
here we have this pre-factor and then
the first derivative of the power series
note that the power is now q plus s
which we get by combining the q plus s
minus 1 power here with the r factor all
the way over here
moving on we have the third term here
which gives this long pre-factor
times the power series
and finally all of this equals zero
so starting with the differential
equation for v at the top here we have
then expanded v as a power series as
shown here and this is the latest
expression that we got for the
differential equation when using the
expansion of v
to simplify this further we can combine
this factor of r squared in the
denominator here with this power over
here to get a power of q plus s minus 2.
we can then rewrite the whole expression
starting with the sum over q
then grouping together the q plus s
minus two powers
and then the q plus s powers
and all is still equal to zero
feel free to pause here again to double
check this last step but all we've
literally done is to rearrange the terms
the next thing we need is to look at the
boundary condition at the top here
we can now rewrite this condition
expressing v as a power series which
when evaluated at the origin must vanish
for this equation to hold we must have
that s must be strictly larger than zero
otherwise we would have a constant
non-zero term in the sum that wouldn't
vanish at the origin
so putting everything together we have
that the power series expansion
coefficients must obey this equation at
the top and that the boundary condition
means that s must be positive
whenever we have a power series equals
zero then we must have that the
coefficients in front of every single
power exactly vanish
now inconveniently in the expression we
have here every term contains two
different powers q plus s minus two here
and q plus s here
and this means that we need to be extra
careful when setting the coefficients of
each power to zero
to explore what is going on
let's look at the first few powers
explicitly and to simplify notation for
now we will call this first term aq
and this second term bq
let's start with the lowest power in the
series which is s minus 2.
the term proportional to the a
coefficient here gives a power of s
minus two when q equals zero which means
that we end up with this term
proportional to c zero
for the term proportional to the b
coefficient here the lowest power in
this term is s
so it does not contribute to this term
which has a power of s minus 2.
as every power in the top equation must
vanish then these coefficients of the
first term must be equal to zero
the next power is s minus one
the a term gets a power of s minus one
when q is equal to one and we have this
term proportional to c one and again the
b term doesn't contribute
we finally require that this coefficient
of the r to the power s minus 1 vanishes
the next power is s
the a term gives a power of s when q is
equal to two and we have this term
proportional to c two
and now the b term does contribute with
its lowest power which corresponds to
the q equals zero term so we end up with
a term proportional to c zero again to
obey the top equation the coefficients
of rs
must vanish
and we could go on like this term by
term
and the general power q plus s has
contributions from the a term
proportional to c q plus 2 and from the
b term proportional to c q
and again these coefficients must vanish
what does this all mean
in order to determine the form of the v
function we need to determine the value
of all the expansion coefficients and
these equations here will allow us to do
so
let's start with the first one
corresponding to the power s minus 2.
so this is the first equation that the
expansion coefficients must obey
using this expression up here for a q we
can write down a0 explicitly by setting
q equal to 0
and we get the pre-factor
multiplying the first term plus the
second term
we can now insert this expression for a0
into the equation up here and end up
with c0 multiplying the expression we
just got for a zero and all equal to
zero
and remember that by definition c0 is
the first non-zero coefficient which
means that this bracket must vanish to
obey this equation
in principle there are two possible
solutions either s is equal to minus l
or s is equal to l plus one
however remember that the boundary
condition that forces the function v to
vanish at the origin implies that s must
be strictly larger than zero
and remembering also that the quantum
number l is non-negative
then these two results together mean
that this solution up here is not
possible
and in turn this means that the only
valid solution is
s equals l plus one
and this result fixes s
okay so going back to our set of
equations we see that the next one
corresponds to the power s minus one
using the general expression for aq up
here we can write down a1 explicitly
the equation for c1 here then becomes
this
in the discussion of the vanishing of
the previous power we established that s
equals l plus one and this implies that
this term in brackets here is not equal
to zero
it then follows that this equation will
only be true if c1 is zero
and overall this means that there is no
c1 coefficient in the power series of v
now going back to our set of equations
we're now ready to look at the general
power q plus s
using this equation here we can insert
the expressions we have for a and b to
get c q plus 2 then the expression for a
q plus 2
plus c q plus the expression for b q
all equal to 0.
from the lowest power equation we know
that s equals l plus one and using this
expression for s in the various
instances here here and here we end up
with this new term proportional to the c
q plus two coefficient
and with this new term proportional to
the cq coefficient
in this step i have made some trivial
rearrangement of terms so feel free to
pause here to cross check this
substitution
overall we've ended up with a recurrence
relation between c q plus 2 and c q
and we can rearrange the terms and write
it in this more conventional form with c
q plus 2 over c q
equal to this long numerator
over this long denominator
let's recap
we are seeking a solution to this
differential equation up here subject to
this boundary condition
we have started by postulating a
solution in the form of a power series
that we write like this
and we've now established that the
expansion coefficients in this power
series must obey this recurrence
relation between c q plus 2 and c q
and we also have that z 0 is different
from 0 by definition while we found that
c1 vanishes
with this information we're now ready to
understand the form that the power
series takes
as c1 is zero and the recurrence
relation relates expansion coefficient c
q with c q plus two
then we can conclude that c q will
vanish for all odd q
as c0 is non-zero
in general we will have non-zero
coefficients with even q
and we'll be able to write all of them
as proportional to c0
this means that we will be able to write
the full power series in terms of the c0
expansion coefficient
and finally we will be able to fix c0
itself by normalizing the resulting wave
function
the next question we explore is whether
the series is finite or infinite
mathematically we can have both options
but we'll see in a moment that for
normalizable solutions we can only have
a finite series
let's first suppose that we have an
infinite series
to be clear remember that we are
considering the series expansion of the
v function like this
in this case we can take the limit of
large q for the ratio of c cubed plus 2
over c q
and using this expression up here we get
this prefactor
the dominant term in the numerator is h
bar omega q and the dominant term in the
denominator is q squared
simplifying we end up with two m omega
over h bar multiplying one over q
this means that if we have an infinite
series then for very large q
the ratio of consecutive coefficients
tends to this value
let's keep this in our mind and we will
come back to it in a moment but first we
need to consider an extra ingredient
to understand what the limit we just
discussed means we will now show that it
is the same limit as that of a rather
simple function that we can easily
analyze
let's consider the power series
expansion of this exponential
we can write the exponential as this sum
over p of the usual power expansion for
an exponential and for convenience we're
going to rewrite it as the sum over p of
an expansion coefficient a to p
times the power
where a to p is simply the original
expansion coefficient
we can now calculate the ratio a 2p plus
2 over a to p plugging in this
definition we get this for the numerator
and this for the denominator
the two factorial terms simplify to one
over p plus one
and the two powers simplify to m omega
over h bar
you can now probably see where we're
going
if we set q equal to 2p
then we can rewrite the ratio as a q
plus 2 over a q
which is equal to this fraction
involving q
and this factor
taking the limit of large q we end up
with 2 m omega over h bar
multiplying 1 over q
so let's now go back to our series
expansion for the function v
we've just established that if we
consider this exponential as a power
series then the limit of large q for the
ratio of consecutive expansion
coefficients is equal to this expression
now these two expansions are slightly
different because of this power of s
here in this first expansion which is
not present in the expansion of the
exponential
however we can think of it as simply
providing a rigid shift in the
comparison of the expansion coefficients
between the two series which becomes
irrelevant in the limit that q tends to
infinity
overall this means that both limits for
large q are the same
and in turn this means that if our
series expansion for v is infinite then
the v function behaves like this
exponential for higher order terms in
the expansion
but this is a problem because this
exponential has a positive argument so
it diverges for large r
this means that v is a physically
unacceptable solution
because the resulting wave function
would not be normalizable
now how can we avoid this unphysical
solution for v
well
physically relevant solutions are such
that the power series must have a finite
number of terms so we must have a finite
series
we'll explore what that implies in a
moment but first a quick aside
having an infinite series which is a
mathematically valid solution leads to
the physically invalid solution we
already found when we solved the
differential equation in the limit of
large r but now appearing for the full
equation
so how can we make this power series
finite
there must exist some value k
such that c q is equal to zero for all q
larger than k looking at the recurrence
relation up here we see that the c q
plus 2 expansion coefficient will be 0
if the numerator here is equal to 0.
so the series will terminate at c k
if the numerator of the recurrence
relation vanishes which means that h bar
omega times k plus l plus one
plus one half h bar omega
minus e kl
equals zero
rearranging we get that the energy is
equal to h bar omega times k plus l plus
three halves
and remember that the label k here can
only take non-negative even integer
values
while the label l here can only take
non-negative integer values
so by insisting that the series must be
finite we have now come to a key result
the energy of the 3d isotropic quantum
harmonic oscillator is quantized and the
energy levels are given by this
expression
an important feature of these
eigenvalues is that they are highly
degenerate and we explore more about
this in the companion video so don't
forget to check it out
okay that's it
after this admittedly very long
mathematical derivation we now have all
the ingredients that we need to study
the energy eigenvalues here and
eigenfunctions here of the 3d isotropic
quantum harmonic oscillator hamiltonian
written as essential potential here
we will finish with a brief summary of
the key results which we then use as a
starting point in the companion video to
explore a few examples of the
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions so don't
miss that video
the full eigenfunction psi
is given by the product of a radial part
and an angular part
this angular part here is the same for
any central potential and is given by
the spherical harmonics
the radial part here depends on the
precise form of the radial potential
what we've done today is to solve a
complex differential equation to
determine this radial part and to do so
we've taken a rather large number of
steps
first we've rewritten the rail function
in terms of a new function u like this
then by considering the limit of large r
we've defined yet another function v
which is related to the u function via
this expression
next we've written the function v in a
power series like this
in terms of expansion coefficients c
and the lowest power s in the expansion
is equal to l plus 1.
finally we've shown that the expansion
coefficients obey a recurrence relation
between c q plus 2 and cq which is equal
to this pre-factor multiplied by this
long numerator
over this long denominator
we also have that the first non-zero
expansion coefficient is c0
while c1 is equal to 0.
this means that all odd expansion
coefficients vanish and that all even
expansion coefficients can be written in
terms of c0
we can then complete the solution by
fixing c0 through normalizing the wave
function
and this is it this is all we need to
determine the eigenfunctions
once we've determined what these c
expansion coefficients are we can
construct v
once we have v we can construct u
once we have u we can construct the
radial function
and once we have r we can finally build
the eigenfunctions
with this recipe we can build any
eigenfunction we want and we look at a
few examples of how to do this
explicitly in the companion video
well i hope you've liked the maths so
what next
i really encourage you to check out the
companion video where we explore the
first few energy eigenvalues and eigen
functions of the 3d isotropic oscillator
and you should also check out our series
of videos on the hydrogen atom where we
use a very similar strategy to solve the
eigenvalue equation and as always if you
liked the video please subscribe